[Music]
hello
and welcome to this discussion on the
land of the free my name is isabel
hilton and i'll be chairing the session
the land of the free is an idea that
along with the american dream is
drilled into the political consciousness
of every child and adult in the united
states
but after a recent rocky patch for the
american dream
president biden finally made it to the
inauguration to reassure us that
democracy
will prevail in some ways though
democracy
has never felt less secure millions of
trump voters
still refuse to accept the results of
november's
presidential election and there have
even been concerns from the left at
twitter's decision
to remove trump from its platform so are
these things indications
of the end of liberal democracy as the
dominant political ideal
are these troubles in the united states
signs that democracy itself is flawed
or will normal service indeed be
restored and the land of the free return
to find its claim of the global moral
high ground
strengthened through this recent turmoil
well to discuss this and other current
questions i'm joined by
jason brennan professor of strategy
economics ethics and public policy at
georgetown university
and the author of the ethics of voting
why not capitalism
and against democracy sarah elliott the
chair of republicans overseas uk
veteran of many republican campaigns who
has written about how she learned to
love donald trump
and by john sopo north america editor
for the bbc
and co-host of the bbc podcast americast
and author of the just published
unprecedented
welcome all now we're going to start our
uh
conversation and you have exactly three
minutes
uh to address the same question is
is democracy at this point a flawed
ideal is it something we should still be
holding up
jason perhaps we could start with you
yes well thank you and thank you for
having me this afternoon and my morning
uh i'm known as a critic of democracy
but i tend to think of myself as
democracy's best fan and the reason i'm
it's best fan is because i like it
exactly as much as it deserves
to be liked i tend to think of democracy
the way i think of the british heavy
metal brand uh
iron maiden i think they're wonderful
but they have a lot of albums that are
terrible in the early 90s
and similarly democracy might be the
best political system that we've come up
with so far
nevertheless having 70 years plus of
experience and
research studying what is going on in
democracy and how it actually functions
we've learned that it has built-in
systematic flaws and to illustrate that
let me start by talking about the theory
of democracy
which pretty much all of us learn in
primary school
in any democratic country that theory
says
what happens is voters start with a set
of interests and concerns and things
that they care about
they then go and learn how the world
works they discover the facts about
politics and what politics is able to do
they form a theory of some sort about
how the economy works and on the basis
of this they form
some sort of ideology and then on the
basis that ideology they look and find a
political party that best matches their
own ideals and values
and vote for that party or maybe vote
for a secondary party if that party is
too small or unlikely to win we all do
this at the same time
and then politicians who want power
supposedly will try to implement the
policies that
the modal voter the median voter or at
least the majority of some sort wants
and thus democracy is supposed to be
responsive to our interests
now if that's the story it's a wonderful
story but it's not really true
because what research has found over the
past 70 years is that the overwhelming
majority of voters are completely
uninformed they
know almost nothing about politics when
they consume news they look for
information that simply reaffirms
whatever it is they currently believe
and they're immune to new information
the overall majority of voters actually
are not even very ideological ideology
is actually the province of the elite
maybe only 10
of people in the uk or the us are
genuinely ideological and vote on that
basis
and the reason for this we join
political tribes in the same way we
largely joined sports
teams as fans why are we like this
because of bad incentives unfortunately
our votes don't count for much
if i vote one way or vote the other way
the same thing will happen everybody
knows this
and so we are what we call in economics
rationally ignorant and rationally
irrational
we know that our votes don't matter very
much unless we don't have an incentive
to use them
in a highly productive way it's a
built-in flaw inside of democracy
and we can't fix it unless we somehow
fix the incentive structure that makes
us ignorant
and irrational well incentivized to be
ignorant and irrational that's pretty
damning
uh sarah yes democracy
um well democracy is defined but by
government by the people especially the
rule of the majority
and on its face democracy doesn't seem
like a bad idea
it means that people get to choose their
government
and their elected officials and so forth
but where the idea of democracy may be
flawed
is it's tricky to implement it and
implement it well
so the founders of the united states
were very much aware of this
they wanted to create a system of how do
you respect
and give voice to the majority as well
as respect the minority
and have them included in the political
discussion
so that the minority will not be
or will not live under the tyranny of
the majority
and also there would be a truly
pluralistic society
and you're able to maximize individual
freedom
because with democracy the thought is
that freedom is then
the outcome or the consequence so how do
you control the passions
of the time so that decisions affecting
the whole
are well thought out that they're
reasoned and tempered with concern for
all
so that you prevent the whims and
the emotions and ignorance of the mob
from carrying the day
so the american founders looked at
history
and saw how well-intentioned pure
democracies had failed
in this regard and thus they created a
constitutional republic
so a republic is where government
supreme power resides and a body of
citizens entitled to vote
and is exercised by elected officials
and representatives
thus the u.s constitution created
institutions
to provide checks and balances on the
impassioned whims of the people
so we have three branches of government
you
have two senators from each state you
have representation by population
and it's why it takes a super majority
of the us
congress and three quarters of the
states to change the constitution
and it's why we have the electoral
college
this is all in an effort to secure
maximum freedom for the people
so that the will of the people is
genuinely protected
so the idea of a pure democracy is not
bad
but in order to have one where all
voices are heated or feel like they're
heard
um it's very difficult and that's why
the american founders created
the constitutional republic and as
benjamin franklin was famous for saying
when asked what he and the others had
just done
he said we've made a republic if you can
keep it
so is democracy flawed
yes this is why we've had to create
and the us constitution and bill of
rights and
and have a republic but i think the
essence of democracy is important
and is still the best form of government
we have
thank you sarah so we are i think fairly
clear that it's
complicated to build and maintain a
democracy but john i
bring back to the question of whether
the ideal itself
is flawed well
thank you very much and lovely to be
with you all um i'll start with the
churchill quote which i'm sure you're
all familiar
that is democracy is the worst form of
government except for all the others
and i think if you make that your
starting point
is it flawed yes is it a flawed
concept no because i still think that
going back to churchill
except when you look at all the other
options democracy is the best thing we
have got out there
and just let me talk a moment about some
of the things that are unique to a
democracy
or you know that are particularly
safeguarded in a democracy
and one that i think is particularly
true of the united states where you have
a first amendment which guarantees
uh freedom of speech uh you have the
rule of law you have protection of
minorities
you have safety nets and so all these
things are trying to create a civil
society
and where you are keeping as sarah has
just
spoken about the majority of the people
happily
happy and you don't have that tyranny of
the majority and so the american
constitution i think is the most
brilliantly designed document
of checks and balances where you can
keep all these things
sort of in balance and you are worried
the the founding fathers were
desperately worried about an over mighty
state
and that was what they felt that they
need to put in place
to have a sort of check on all of that i
want to focus
on one of the things because we're going
to have a conversation
which is very contemporary and one of
the things that i just
spoke about was the rule of law
and america's fragility
as a democracy came to the fore
in the wake of the november election
when donald trump maintained
that the election had been stolen
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas